shot and game are just about synced for
the tie
lebron ties it at 105.
well now it's all up to your defense the
overtimes in a row maybe
absolutely because lebron set it up the
play was called
handoff from montrez elevate shoot
splash that tied it
sends it to a third consecutive game
where the lakers
are going into o t second time in a row
against
the thunder and let's see if they can
and by the way the
ot game a couple of games ago the foot
going to the rim lebron will pass it off
to matthews
for three yes sir
wesley
wesley matthews hit a big three-pointer
in the last game on the other side in
the corner this time
in the opposite corner and he knocks
down a big three
lakers lead by three with 41 seconds
again
your defense has to get you a stop here
you get a stop on this possession
this game could be over
that's some defined by mr james again
i like the no hesitation by wesley
matthews you got an open look you take
it
seconds left got to get it in throws it
away
lebron the save they still have time
with one
on its way so lebron makes the defensive
play
to help win the game good play by lebron
terrible inbounds pass bill you see the
thing that had no
zip on it and lebron just ran through it
and got a hand on it
lakers very very fortunate so the number
one defense comes up with a stop at the
end
look at that look at that inbound pass i
mean very very
easily could have been intercepted and
kept by lebron
and then when he tipped it in williams
had no choice but to try to
throw it to the rim i said make him come
back to get it they were coming back and
it was almost
the lakers that got it great hustle by
the can